jm eu tô preso talvez alguém dando então
eu devo memória o tem ovo tem ovo dante
tem ovo que o artur não havia previsto
para todo o pessoal de quem fala é o
dark sejam muito bem vindos à margem
dobrou eo último vídeo perguntei a todos
vocês se criam que o investigasse a
floresta é assombrada que eu tenho
proposta da romã ea minha idéia inicial
pessoal era investigar esta floresta à
noite mas à noite quando nós estamos em
casa e hoje muitos barulhos de que 20 da
floresta então eu não vou fazer isso
porque o som e chegam eu não quero ou
não quero encontrar isso lembrou o bruxo
sei lá nos nao sei isto quicou dentro
vai mudar na ilha andrey outra não por
ser de investigação floresta então o que
nós vamos fazer hoje só eu já mandei um
recado à saída de um escanteio
[Música]
qual é o plano em chegar aqui floresta
enquanto estado e porque assim posso ver
mais ou menos a zonas distintas áreas
que têm plantas que picam se ela estiver
tudo bem eu vou investigar a floresta à
noite e quem sabe passar uma noite ela
encampa duelo disse com alguma hesitação
né
eu não sei se fuma mas que só vocês
comentarem muito aqui embaixo da que
passa uma noite na floresta eu talvez
vou pensar mas só se você tem muitos já
agora só deixei muito lhe quiserem ver
mais vídeos deste investigar florestas
porque esta floresta aqui eu não sei se
é assim tão extensa você porque eu vou
investigar agora mas aqui na localidade
onde eu estou tem muitas florestas
triplo em cima de uma floresta gigante
então eu posso explorar isso mais tarde
portanto vocês gostarem deste conteúdo
comenta y deixei muito likes foi 95 no
canal e cream pessoas quiserem claro e
agora vamos investigar a nossa floresta
deve ajudar a ir embora tão primeiro
passo vai ser a subir ficando meu deus é
muito alto em aquecimento de subida dos
garotos mas não só como é que tá ali do
outro lado
é muito assustador no final de som e
ilusão já reparaste que oito consegue
ouvir assim carros a partir dali do
outro lado da estrada
nós vamos lá seguir para dora que não vá
já então se abraçar caso não consiga
voltar na casa assombrada cobra tanto
prometeu voltar o que só comentei dólar
que volta o que não houve foi que de
rock
ai meu deus tá lá no bojo de tudo
a câmara quer mostrar o que eu saí só
vejam só continua a dar vos vejo nem dá
eu acho que nem vai dar pra andar ali
tem aqui um caminho até à frente e ele
já não há caminho é só é só floresta com
ele isso mesmo mas vamos tentar agora lá
comandante tomou a câmera e sair daqui
com a boca no chão
calma calma já que eu acho que essa vai
ser a aventura da minha vida embora eu
acho que a partida não conta com pico
a atual é agora vamos investigar a
floresta foi aí não vai dar pra andar
aqui meu tem muitas plantas
a turma ficar para este ano tem picos
meu nem sei ainda como top car a este
caminho aqui haja um cortejo com teerã
aí é eu devia ter vindo para aqui com a
voz é a proteção já para andar mas vamos
tentar andar aqui dentro
o comentário de alguém dante minel
memória
à esquerda o brasil
não não era uma pessoa que aconteceu
está a ser filmado em captar a câmera
juros em outubro para ouvir qualquer
coisa numa boa e vai daí alguém eu estou
muito assustado mas não respondeu uma
obra onde sei lá quem mais que nem pra
lá não acaba e até lá no fundo tem muita
abstenção aquilani estou aqui na porta
principal e mal conseguia andar
então vamos tentar em ficar aqui com
muita calma eu já tenho dúvida que
alguns objetos
olha aí tem um vaso vazio e ia ser aqui
da casa que tal tem de tocar fora
não sei porquê e agora nós temos um
caminho que por aqui acho que dá pra
isso aqui dá pra ir muito bem pra esse
lado eu acho que é muito difícil então
acho que vamos pôr aqui primeiro item a
companhia vai por dentro da casa
agora uma coisa que já sabe
tem muita coisa errada nisso
tem muita coisa que ele isso fala que dá
pra na espécie a cortar a água toma
conta muito tomar contá muito falei essa
planta tem muito espinho tem que ter
mais cuidado tem mais madeira lei tem
coisas ruins a cabeça
[Música]
o tem um bicho e vamos continuar a
avançar
inclusive está muito calor aqui então é
isso ai meu deus está no local a sério
pessoal incrível
é incrível a divisão sob a lei dentre
estudantes
tudo foi isto eu sei que isto para um
filme com a ordem não não é assim eu tô
aqui dando para para para para o futuro
que tirar alguma coisa da silva e
qualquer coisa que não é visto tomando o
que eu tô maluco tomando um copo ficar
maluco só vocês viram eu juro estava com
alguma coisa vou tentar entrar
ai meu deus já tem um boné hoje eu sou
isso não acaba não não eu não vou
conseguir entrar aqui nunca tem muitas
plantas aqui só tá difícil está difícil
vai ser muito difícil explorar está a
rodar a volta de um naco de cobrar aqui
quem estava tudo ok eu não vou buscar
mais esta área ainda sai de um salão que
não sou eu não vou arriscar só vou
tentar agora outro lado eu vou tentar
ver por aqui
como podem ver de novo da proibição a 50
estão aqui do lado
ok vou ter mais cuidado aqui dá pra na
final
aqui tem uma tampa que eu não sei o que
haja um pequeno uma tampa de uma coisa
de 30 saiu a eu acho que vou conseguir
andar por aqui uma coisa como essas
coisas vêm cá para isso é que dá para
ser uma peça de decoração são lá muito
estranho a partir daqui estamos a
encontrar coisas desconhecidas deixadas
pelos jovens
ok vamos continuar a ouvir coisas mas eu
acho que já sou eu ficar maluco aqui no
chão que tem mais
só não vamos cortar vamos cortar
qualquer só esqueceram isso eu não vou
passar aqui eu vou tentar já ir em
frente e vamos tentar eu nem quer saber
eu vou passar aqui mesmo eu tô aí tudo
que não é mas também muito bem
ok ok vamos tentar avançar opera em
qualquer confusão ou o que isto eu abrir
outra vez para para para para para de
ouvir outra vez porque tá aí não é um
bicho de antes for um bicho ainda macaco
grande está fazendo muito barulho em
junho estou com muito medo muito menor e
tudo só já olha estou muito nervoso mas
eu encontrei alguma coisa é um osso
encontrei um osso
é isso é um osso mesmo foi lá estou eu
contei aqui a macaca os seus curiosos
nem vou tocar o tema cuba que o vou
embora vou embora
aí eu cortei o o osternack no braço
meu deus não eu não devia ter vindo a
acontecer ficação a só que vocês acham
que eu devia avançar 8,4 eu vou
encontrar muita coisa assustadora quito
houve muito barulho e também estão é
brinquedo é quem quer que seja que está
ao dispor um ser humano
estamos a ver agora e acho que eu sou o
tipo de ataque a qualquer coisa à
realidade das costas
eu jogava eu tô preso eu já tô eu tô eu
estou agora qualquer coisa no peru aqui
acho que já estou vendo
vejam só que eu encontrei olha aí tem
que uma zona bem estranha aqui é
impossível caminhar aqui também é
impossível caminhar e que também é
impossível caminhar eu acho que consegui
chegar até o ponto máximo ok mas eu vou
tentar olhar aqui pro chão e ver se
conseguimos encontrar alguma coisa ok
ele tem alguns postos que têm algum lixo
mas nada mais nada de estranho nada que
justifique os barulhos que houve que no
mato
então vamos embora daqui é a única
solução que eu tenho agora é sair daqui
não há mais caminho a só se for pra lá
só pra lá só subir ali ele acha que deve
dar
mas mesmo assim tem muita planta aqui
com espinhos vai ser muito arriscado
ok você está sendo aqui outra vez este
ano mais difícil para qualquer coisa
aplicar nas costas
tu vai tomar aí eu tentei baixar muito
aqui
ok já conseguiu voltar dando eu tenho
lado de guga ao lado
meu deus eu não morri porque é infantil
é isso que está a disputar
não estamos sós não estamos aqui só voz
o som o alto eo ninho tem um ninho
nintendo não é um link por fótons claque
diabo só pode ser dar né pergunta se
encontra um link que dava só lá vou
tentar enfiar a câmera ali dentro é pra
vocês conseguirem ver e eu já vi também
o que acabou só tirar aqui um micro por
não poder jogar o que é que tem alguma
coisa pessoal
só não consegui ver eu vou indicar que o
micro até mesmo fazer algum barulho mas
vamos lá então que tenho e vou tentar
tirar com muito cuidado e eu gosto de
fazer não não conta e ovo tem ovo dante
tem ovo e eu acreditar do ninho
por isso vivem no solo e tempero aqui
unisul danton eo wo não saiu bem em
preto olha aí
por ser uma galinha escuro e eu acho que
tem mais eq ficou sem padrinho muita
calma
ontem outro vôo que ele isso e é bem
pesado só comentei em baixa o que vocês
acham que animal é isto mesmo tem pelo
estudo não está algodão animal com
algodão lei é muito estranho isso aqui
só pode ser um novo desafio mas com a
palavra eu nunca vi algo assim o que
pato não é assim ovo de galinha não é
assim obter poder mim não é sensual
certo com muita vontade por tiro ou
viver o que tem ali dentro mas eu não
quero destruir uma vida assim à tona
então comenta embaixo que você já sabe o
que é que este ovo e comentem também se
quiserem que eu abra um novo destes 1 ou
sol e vamos ver o que tem dentro o que
falta vou deixar os jogos aqui e eu
acabei por destruir um pouquinho mas o
que eu vou fazer eu vou construir agora
uma linha se muito rápido pois fazer o
vídeo eu vou construir um moinho e vou
deixar ele como estava a mãe desse
animal com coelhos ovos de estar à
espera que os jogos nacionais
então eu vou tentar fazer um ninho e
voltar a colocar ele mas foi uma coisa
bizarra eu tenho que destruir o software
da ufla ainda do bruxo
eu estou a brincar mas pode ser uma
coisa muito pesada mas pessoal eu vou
ficar à espera da vossa resposta comenta
muito em baixo que que investiga eu vou
investigar também esse eu não consegui
descobrir o que é isto ou por de novo eu
vou perder só vou sair daqui da floresta
a
o delta tejo daqui jogo aqui dentro uma
câmera e uma câmera
eu tenho cuidado ai ai morri do coração
agora é o gol eu ia caindo angola eu ia
caindo agora meu deus como é isso que é
muito curta para as pernas é e como
assim
e com o tema que também passei só pra
vocês tenham gostado que os filhos que
quiserem mais investigações de que na
floresta deixa muito líquido e não
esqueçam eu ainda vou investigar esta
floresta à noite portanto deixou muito
mais mesmo e foi 9 no canal eu sou dark
se inscrevam é só clicar aqui no botão
dezembro ele é isso fica vai até a
próxima